In the film Self / Less, which will be shown on July 10, Mr. Ben Kingsley moves his consciousness
To the body of Ryan Reynolds in an attempt to stay alive forever and become virtually immortal.
In a process called 'projection' which looks really wonderful
I mean who does not want extra time to realize his dreams with a young body of his choice?
Try to become a professional athlete or solve the biggest dilemmas of the world.
But is the projection process realistic? Can you become immortal in this way?
First, you must understand how memories are stored. Your brain is a mass of 3 lb (1.5 kg)
Of a lipid tissue containing 86 billion brain cells called neurons. Electricity
Or chemicals between them, neurons can send signals to each other. Most neuroscientists believe
That memory is stored as a network of neurons that form connections between them.
They all work at the same time. Every time memory is recalled, that network of neurons works together.
In fact, scientists have shown that some parts of the brain are electrified,
It is possible to make someone remember some memories
For example, the smell of toast.
To carry a memory, we can simply follow the path of the neurons that are activated when you think about them.
As we explained in the previous video, scientists have done so.
Using computers to simulate these patterns of activated neurons with real images
Or scenes, we can read people's minds to a limited degree.
Many scientists believe that someday it will become possible
Find a map of all the neurons in the brain and the links that connect them. This map will be called Connectedum.
The United States and the European Union have launched massive research programs
This particular goal is taken into consideration, such as the organizations in Self / Less.
This task will probably take decades, but when it ends, scientists will be able to build
A working computer model, you can consider it as a virtual brain that allows signal transmission
Between neurons through artificial nerve clamps.
If downloading memories is possible, what about introducing them? This also comes close to being a fact
With a technique called photoreceptor. This involves injecting certain neurons
With a nucleic acid of algae that produces a light-sensitive protein on the surface of its cells.
When the brain is highlighted, the protein stimulates and activates only the neurons involved.
In this way, scientists can artificially activate cells to group neurons
Associated with specific memories.
This all sounds really scary, and it may make you think that a scenario like this is the one that's introduced in
A Self / Less film may not be out of reach. But there are some reasons to make you comfortable.
Our brains are incredibly complex, perhaps so complex that you can not copy.
The number of clamps is 1,000 times greater than the number of stars in the Milky Way galaxy.
Above all, your brain is constantly reworking itself, creating new and active links
The old ones are gone. It is the reflection of you at this moment of time,
It took the time of your whole life to be found.
A copy of your mind will be just a tradition. And the moment it begins
By incorporating ideas, memories and experiences, he will become someone else. Which helps us in some way
How much we are unique. But with increasingly sophisticated technology,
Who knows what the future holds for us! Perhaps such a world in Self / Less is not too far away.
Be sure to watch the movie that will be on July 10 - we will be there
We will be excited to hear your opinion.
You can click on the screen or use the link in the description for a quick look
Subscribe to more weekly science videos.